hey guess what time is revealing its
list of the 100 most influential people
in the world and one of them is our girl
sitting right here Gayle King is being
honored with her own cover in the
magazine's annual series filmmaker Ava
Duvernay wrote the tribute to Gayle
calling her one of the all-time great
broadcast interviewer she also just
silver Ida said cover nor can you put
that cover back I think that's one of
the most awesome pictures and
congratulations so well deserves yes I
am so humbled I have to say nor when
they first told me Samantha our of our
PR department broke it broke the news to
me and I said are you sure Samantha are
you sure it's one of those things I've
been going to this event for the past
1012 years and I'm just excited to be in
the room because as you know there's
always somebody you want to meet
somebody you want to talk to and it's
just great to be in the company so to be
one of the honorees is very very
humbling to me I'm very exciting you
know I started my career at time and so
being on the time cover has special you
know resonance for me and to see you up
there and thanks so deserving and so
beautiful it's just fantastic I'm gonna
buy a couple of copies and we're gonna
show you some of the other big names on
the list that's coming up right after
the break but until then congratulations
again thank you